wie forscher fische zum laufen bringen
wie man 15.000 euro durch rumliegen
verdient und warum ein es ein gefängnis
für unseren körper ist das sind drei der
themen jetzt in den krieg zum topf alten
news der woche wie fische laufen lernen
amerikanische forscher haben zwischen
das laufen beigebracht die
wissenschaftler haben einen ausschnitt
der evolution nachgestellt und dieses
erstaunliche ergebnis erzielt die
anatomischen veränderungen spiegeln die
entwicklung von fischen zu
landwirbeltieren wieder die beobachteten
verhaltensänderungen könnten zeigen wie
sich die ersten schritte der fische an
land auf die evolution ausgewirkt haben
die ersten wirbeltiere kamen vor 400
millionen jahren an land und
entwickelten sich zu den vorläufern der
amphibien die forscher um emily ständen
von der university of ottawa haben
diesen prozess in einem eher
ungewöhnlichen versuch nachgestellt sie
zogen fische die luft atmen können über
einen zeitraum von acht monaten an land
auf und beobachteten die veränderung an
ihrem körperbau zum vergleich wurde eine
zweite versuchsgruppe mit fischen im
wasser aufgezogen die fische an land
müssen mit einer höheren schwerkraft und
anderen bewegungsabläufen zurechtkommen
deshalb waren sie gezwungen sich
anzupassen
mit highspeed kameras wurden dann die
fische beim laufen beobachtet
erstaunlich in dieser verhältnismäßig
kurzen zeitspanne hatten sich die land
fische bereits an die neuen
lebensbedingungen gewöhnt 15.000 euro
fürs nichtstun für die raumfahrt für
eine studie sucht das deutsche zentrum
für luft und raumfahrt teilnehmer denen
auf einen längeren zeitraum bettruhe in
einer schräglage von sechs grad also so
ganz leicht verordnet wird
die forscher wollen herausfinden wie die
gesundheit und leistungsfähigkeit der
astronauten sichergestellt werden kann
hintergrund der studie ist die
schwächung der muskeln durch die
schwerelosigkeit und durch die kopf
schieflage der kopf wird also tiefer
gelegt wird die schwerelosigkeit
simuliert durch die bettruhe werden die
muskelgruppen vor allem in den beinen
nicht mehr beansprucht und bauen sich ab
die kopf schieflage während der métro
verursacht zudem
eine flüssigkeit verschiebung innerhalb
des körpers wie sie auch im weltall
auftritt durch verschiedene experimente
aus den bereichen herz kreislauf muskeln
und knochen ernährung und stoffwechsel
und weitere werden die physiologischen
veränderungen während der langzeit
bettruhe untersucht weitere infos gibt
es unten im link in der video
beschreibung und eine
aufwandsentschädigung gibt es dann für
alle die angenommen werden für diese
versuchsreihe wenn sie an allen vor
nachuntersuchungen und während der
stationären phase vollständig mit war
leben im antarktischen eis und
wahrscheinlich auf dem mars in 800
metern tiefe unter dem antarktischen eis
gibt es leben
forscher um brand christa von der
louisiana state university in baton
rouge konnten erstmals sicher nachweisen
dass bakterien und andere einzellige
mikroorganismen in der kälte des eises
existieren
die mikroorganismen überleben bei
völliger dunkelheit und temperaturen von
knapp unter null grad celsius und
ernähren sich von nährstoffen die sie
aus dem gestein ziehen schreiben die
wissenschaftler im fachmagazin nature
die neuen ergebnisse sind ein
meilenstein in der polarforschung und
werfen sogar die frage auf ob es nicht
beispielsweise auf dem mars ähnliche
gesteins fressende bakterien gibt die
wissenschaftler gehen sogar einen
schritt weiter sie meinen es gebe
weitere solcher ökosysteme in den tiefen
der antarktis die generelle existenz von
bakterien und mikroorganismen ist schon
länger vermutet worden
allerdings konnten die amerikanischen
forscher diese these erst jetzt
zweifelsfrei bestätigen
hls eis bucket challenge league
krankheit alles ist derzeit überall
präsent durch die eisberge challenge
erlangt dls association große
aufmerksamkeit bei der aktion geht es
darum sich einen eimer mit eiswasser
über den kopf zu schütten viele leute
und auch sehr viele momente haben die
aktion unterstützt dazu gehören unter
anderem weltfußballer cristiano ronaldo
der ehemalige us präsident george bush
und die sängerin taylor swift aber was
ist eigentlich genau lsl es steht für
anrufe lateralsklerose und bezeichnet
eine nervenkrankheit die nervenzellen im
gehirn und rückenmark werden bei dieser
krankheit mit der zeit immer weiter
beschädigt und zerstört
so dass der patient quasi im eigenen
körper gefangen ist
da unsere nervenbahnen befehle vom
gehirn zum rückenmark und von dort aus
an die muskeln
leighton ist alles super gefährlich denn
so treten zunehmend lähmungen am ganzen
körper auf die tödlich sind im endeffekt
ein sehr prominentes beispiel für die
krankheit ist der britische
astrophysiker stephen hawking da ihm
zeichnet sich die krankheit durch einen
sehr langen krankheitsverlauf aus ärzte
hatten ihm nur wenige jahre prophezeit
als ihm die diagnose 1963 gestellt wurde
durch die aktion auf sozialen netzwerken
unter dem hashtag alles eis bucket
challenge konnten jetzt spenden von
knapp 80 millionen us-dollar gesammelt
werden und mit dem geld soll die
forschung für eine effektivere
behandlung gegen die krankheit jetzt
finanziert werden ich habe das auch
nicht gemacht
falls ihr sehen wollt wie ich mich dabei
angestellt habe schaut in video nach das
ist und der video beschreibung verlinkt
und spendet auch einen kleinen teil es
ist für einen guten zweck und nicht nur
für einen internet hat superhelden
selbstgemacht muskeln wie die
superhelden hulk oder captain america
das ist in der theorie nicht unmöglich
meint jedenfalls der molekularbiologe
sebastian addo von der stanford
university
im prinzip ist das alles gar nicht so
schwer sagt er
mit methylgruppen die an die dna
angehängt werden können sind
veränderungen der einzelnen gene des
menschen möglich der junge
forschungszweig an dem auch sebastian
rieder arbeitet ist die epigenetik
geologen untersuchen dort die
möglichkeiten einzelne gene zu
aktivieren beziehungsweise zu
deaktivieren
das soll unter anderem auch helfen um
krankheiten wie krebs in den griff zu
bekommen
bei einem jungen aus deutschland wurde
vor einigen jahren eine mutation der
gene festgestellt schon mit viereinhalb
jahren konnte er 23 kilogramm hanteln
waagerecht mit den armen heben seine
ausgeprägten muskeln wurden mehrfach in
verschiedenen ländern untersucht und
auch bei mäusen zeigte eine künstlich
hervorgerufenen veränderung der gene
ähnliche auswirkungen das muskel bild
der nagetiere was deutlich ausgeprägter
als das der nicht notierten artgenossen
besonders angetan ist der forscher sind
best innovator vom superhelden alt
seine entstehung im comic natürlich
erklärt der biologe wie folgt
gammastrahlung zersetzt unsere dna unser
körper setzt die einzelnen teile dann
wieder zusammen
allerdings scheint bei dr bruce banner
alias hat dabei einiges durcheinander
gekommen zu sein
das ergebnis ist das große grüne monster
mit den riesigen muskeln
momentan hat die forschung an der
epigenetik aber vor allem in der medizin
ihre schwerpunkte so das waren die top
five - aus dem weg zum de/blog und der
epfl euer smartphone
wenn ihr die haben wollt dafür hier
klicken und hier geht es zum letzten
video hot stocks ampeln gehackt hier
klicken um das video zu sehen und meine
frage an euch habt ihr bei der ice backe
challenge mit gemacht teilt eure videos
unten in den kommentaren ich pack' die
links auch in die wir beschreiben und
mache eine playlist und jetzt heißt es
wie immer bis dann bleibt da